January 6th was it was it a you know uh
[ __ ] show they're just trying to you
know make it look like bigger than it
really is or was it uh credible that
they waste a lot of time and money were
they trying to divide was it a good idea
was it not a good idea I think the
investigation that the doj investigation
into the individuals who went over into
the Congress is worthwhile it's hugely
it may be the biggest investigation
they've ever ever conducted in terms of
the number of people
you're looking at and who were involved
if you wrap in election denial I think
the political investigation is worth it
because the prospect that people will go
into a future election and do the same
thing I think is
is worrisome I I tend not to be sort of
the sky is falling but I would not want
to encourage people to say it's now
acceptable political rhetoric to say the
election was stolen for me and Mitch
McConnell supporting legislation that
sort of changes the game on this I think
is an indicator there are people on both
sides of the aisle a little bit worried
about attitudes in America on elections
election denial
that's different from how culture dealt
with it I think it it once again divided
culture into saying we ought to
immediately prosecute people in the
White House
try that trial can you show me
consistently how all these people told
somebody to go break a law and break a
criminal statute or do you think that
I thought the coverage encouraged people
to say this is the only thing that's
important in America right now it's
important but there's I if there's a lot
of other things going on it's not the
top thing I worry about
um so I thought some of the
investigative work was valuable
especially in terms of not only holding
people accountable but looking forward
and saying how do we change laws to
ensure that election denial isn't part
of the American political culture in
terms of cultural coverage
oh my God this is like whoa this is
overwhelming too much too much okay how
about how about the two impeachments
uh I thought I'm going to say this again
I thought the investigation that Robert
Mueller conducted was
serious and worthwhile as someone who
did
foreign policy for a lifetime suggesting
that it's okay to encourage foreign
powers Russia or others to inject
information into an American election
that is just
that's needs to be investigated
people who attacked Mueller for not
filing charges including people that I
knew at the FBI who who were on
Mueller's team Mueller was the most
straightforward
the best leader I ever saw in government
he looked at this and said again you got
to look at both sides of this argument I
don't I'm not sure that we should we
should or can prosecute these cases so
worth investigating but I thought
Mueller's decision was entirely
defensible in terms of coverage man
again we made it the only thing people
talked about in the midst of serious
conversations we should be having about
why our educational standards are modest
in this country educational or uh Health
Care in this country is excellent access
is still compared to our peer countries
okay life expectancy is dropping
things like obesity and diabetes you
know you might call me again a Pollyanna
but if you want to talk about stuff that
affects an American citizen
Health Care affects an American citizen
a lot more than a Russian impeachment
will so I thought the process was
appropriate the attention was a bit much
in terms of the the final the second
impeachment I thought that was an
egregious abuse of Presidential Power to
ask a foreign leader to investigate a
rival son I think Hunter Biden is worthy
investment investigation that is some
dirty stuff but you can't have
presidential authorities um pressing the
president pressing a foreign leader to
conduct the political investigation
against a criminal investigation against
a rival that's a no you can't do it so
if you like this clip and you want to
watch another one click right here and
if you want to watch the entire podcast
click right here
[Music]